Leonard can't connect [ __ ] dolla
looking to push Lake Thompson running
the floor and the plush see off the good
defense
the Warriors want to play with pace
throw a head attack and klay Thompson
gets away with seven steps but finishes
it in fátima on tile honoring a couple
of the Raptors forgiving the travels and
fleet mass defect that had stolen
Thompson to cook cook up a rehearse gets
knocked down and he'll shoot a couple of
free throw the ball on this pass right
there yep it was up to put on the other
end it turns into a three-point play
[Applause]
Leonard drives inside layup patched at
home and the foul
let it the drive-by curry comes over
wowie
Janie green contestant praise good
[Applause]
siakam one-on-one coverage with draymond
Green I smoked inside stop help doesn't
come all the way go get to your spot any
beat strip VanFleet goes right at your
rep go tough shut up oh thanks at home
how do we get that one to go well just
isolated is very good defense by Gerardo
but a tremendous minute
[Applause]
siakam flips it up and pants at home
each got 30 progressive all night long
getting to his spots and making plays
beautiful often and that's well defended
that's a difficult shot the lead is 11
21 for Leonard on the drive three can't
fish five to shoot
Leonard sees the double-team van fleet
and I've always stood up that's a
two-pointer
Lowry for three
[Applause]
mckinney with the answer down the other
end the Raptors and the franchise's
first appearance in the NBA files get
the victory here in Game one
[Applause]